draaga asks I'm an indie music producer
what tips do you have to program my
content using social media marketing
dragga
what's up your back and I respect that
you're an episode one and to you one day
will be a trivia question so the
question is look you're an indie guy
you're trying to promote I'm actually
gonna move the mic to Steve he's not
even expecting this go there go there do
you have the sound or you're good with
sudden you don't know the cameras got
its own sound yeah go ahead say what you
just said to me
so Shia I looked at your Twitter account
and you posted a remix of a Rihanna
track eight times in the last 24 hours
since we aired the last episode of the
show actually that's a little bit
overwhelming dragon now couple things I
think the thing to really think about is
listening I was actually clicking and so
I've got focused I don't know what he
was doing everybody's replying to
somebody I like the replying in Twitter
that's a tactic look here's here's what
I think it's all about the quality of
the music matters building up your
soundcloud matters how does one do that
one of the ways to really do that is to
become old-school in some ways believe
it or not I'm gonna go left-field on you
how about some music message boards but
not spamming them becoming a part of
that community
how about searching every single person
that tweeted about Rihanna Steve pull it
up every single person who tweeted about
Rihanna let me guess
but I'm gonna think it's a shitload
right and so in that shitload jumping in
and engaging with those people now you
got to spend a lot of time you decided
to do a Rihanna remix not me so that
means you've got to go through it and
it's gonna take you a couple hours
because everybody's be tweeting like
Rihanna's hot [ __ ] Rihanna all that
stuff and you have to find people that
are actually talking about Rihanna's
music which I don't know probably small
percentage of what's going on on Twitter
you've got to jump into that and engage
with it authentically engaging and
you've heard the 19 year old dude move
is not saying check out my track you've
got to just kind of you know jam with
people I would recommend if you're
jamming people and jamming with people
not jamming if you're jamming with
people during that period changing the
URL in your Twitter profile to be a
direct link to the
on a track that's right folks that was a
tactic and that's why I asked Gary Vee
is going to be a big-time show if you're
deciding to do something specific for a
2-day period like draaga should around
engaging people around Rihanna's music
that actually talked about the music I
recommend he changes his Twitter
profiles URL from his probably homepage
or whatever he's got going on to the
actual link to the SoundCloud of that
show because while he's engaging people
gonna be like who the hell's draaga let
me click this link in his URL boom
they're listening to that the viral loop
gets going the viral loop gets going
you